what's happening reject nation Greg Alba
here I'm going to talk about something
that has been on my mind quite a bit
lately
and something I think it's been on a lot
of people's minds lately so I figured
why not chime in I watch all these shows
so I have an opinion here let me express
it Netflix has been canceling a lot of
[ __ ] lately a lot of big [ __ ] they're
shown over the hearts of America right
now it's kind of funny that the
streaming service that produces a
gajillion things a month have canceled
two shows of the Netflix original side
that I actually watch Iron Fist was
cancelled Danny ran and Luke Cage was
canceled as well and personally I loved
both of their official season two's I
wasn't a big fan of irfs season one nor
was anybody I didn't really care for
Danny ran and the defenders that's true
but I thought I'm facin too was a
drastic improvement side plug I did 30
second reactions for reviews on the
Stardust app we do that for a lot of
things and I covered most of Iron Fist
season two over there I cannot be more
pissed this show is over
I didn't just love Iron Fist season two
because it was better I know sometimes
that becomes the barrier for I love it
only because it was better I just
honestly think it was a really good
season because I know that on Rotten
Tomatoes it technically still falls
under the rot inside of the tomato meter
but I also think that at this point when
you're three seasons in I call it three
seasons because the defenders is
essentially another season for each one
of those characters that I think buy the
point when you get to iron fist season
two there's gonna be a good amount of
people who are just not gonna warm up to
the Danny ran side of the defenders
world that's not to say that some people
genuinely just don't like it because
they don't think it's good I just think
that some people are automatically not
going to like it by the way there's
gonna be spoilers here for both of those
seasons so if you haven't seen them you
might want to avoid this
I thought the storyline in season 2 for
Iron Fist was very very personal I
thought the fight scenes were
drastically better keeping it at ten
episodes made for a very well paced
highly engaging show and Finn Jones the
movies was so much better in this
it's easily so much better I mean his
acting chops in certain arenas still
lacks certain levels of depth sure but I
think that because he's clearly a much
better fighter this time around I think
naturally his confidence is that much
higher so his performance just naturally
seems more confident I thought the way
they handled the Meacham storylines was
very engaging Ward you're my man
the merry and Walker characters played
by Alice Eve I thought were great
additions Alice Eve knocked both of
those characters out of the park and I
thought Davos as the main villain made
for very engaging storylines and I love
how he escalated into this guy who just
kept losing more and more control and
the idea of exploring the Iron Fist as
sort of this drug that those who possess
it can become addicted to its power I
thought it was a really interesting
element I thought it got a lot more deep
than I expected it to go my voice is a
little bit hard I just thought the
characters in the dialogue were in so
much better there's this one episode
Davos Colleen Wang Danny ran and joy are
all having dinner together that's most
of the episode there's barely any action
in it and it's mainly in this one
location and I thought that was one of
the more engaging episodes so yeah I
think the writing overall is so much
better and of course the ending with
Kali and winged taking on the iron fist
was so cool she's my favorite so I was
really excited for her and plus all
those scenes essentially teasing the
daughters of the dragon with misty
Knight and Kali and Ling always got me
excited cuz I really want to see that
happen and yeah there was some cheesy
cliffhangers in there Danny ran with the
double wielding iron fist the literally
double wielding guns was very cheesy but
I personally really enjoyed to find out
the show was cancelled yeah that was uh
as a bit of a [ __ ] bum for me I don't
know what that is the first time
anything with iron fist ended and I was
really looking forward to seeing more I
was very hyped and the same goes for
Luke Cage season two I thought all of
Luke eight season two was great there's
kind of some mixed opinions on it I
thought it was very well executed it was
very dark and kind of heavy at times
with this emotional storytelling but
damn the way it ends though cuz there's
a lot of those heroes stories you know
deal with the fine line between hero and
the way that season ends pretty much
Luke Cage crossing over into the
criminal side of things they do a lot of
the storytelling with his Luke Cage
gonna go bad as Luke Cage gonna become a
criminal he's kind of evolving into
something and most of the time a movie
or show would not go there and the way
this season ends
he goes there plus there was a pretty
cool episode of though that featured
Danny ran which gets you excited at the
possibility of a Heroes for Hire
with all the speculation going on
there's been some you know Twitter
comments happening out there of what
they think might be going on and I
completely agree so I wanted to just put
this video out there to say here's why I
think what we're gonna get is a Heroes
for Hire show yes there's a lot of
speculation as to why the shows have
been canceled people are putting up
videos about you know the financial
reasoning behind it a lot of people are
also speculating that the Disney
streaming service coming out that
they're gonna try to transfer these two
shows over there which a I don't want
and B I just don't think that's gonna it
doesn't make sense to me I know that
Netflix does not release the viewership
for their show so for all I know I could
be completely wrong and that these shows
no one tune in for them they made no
money so why would net flix keep them
that that could be one factor but here's
my thing I just really believe they're
messing with the audience's and setting
us up for a surprise announcement of
Heroes for Hire show that will also
feature the daughters of the Dragon
maybe they'll do two separate shows I
think they're gonna combine it into one
series it only makes sense to me that
that would be the approach they take
daredevil season 3 just came out have
not started the show yet so don't spoil
anything and because I'm saying that I'm
not reading a single comment on this
video I mean think about it it's kind of
weird that they would cancel two of the
defenders shows really close to the
release date of daredevil season 3
that's a little bit off I know daredevil
is a completely different show same time
though it's kind of weird all the
defenders were the other side is I think
the Netflix Marvel shows have been
having difficulty staying relevant think
about when the first wave of the
defenders show started coming out
daredevil season 1 yeah Jessica Jones he
is at one stair double season too
awesome for the most part Luke Cage
season 1 first half was great iron fist
season 1 whatever we're still getting
the defenders then the defenders seem to
be a letdown for most people I know
there's
people that love the hell out of that
show but overall I think it was kind of
lackluster for most people myself
included and since the defenders
whenever seasons of these shows come out
you ever noticed the hype for them is
either non-existent or it dies out
really quick there's barely any high
there's barely any talk about them they
kind of just exist now I think when
Netflix is doing is they're thin
assuming us a little bit that's why I'm
coined that word fan assuming
tennis scene danos - ping like they're
freaking us out with the cancellation no
Luke Cage and Danny Rand are dead and
what's happening we're all talking about
the cancellation all of us and what else
is happening fan bases are demanding
that these shows continue to live on
there's weirdly more hype for Iron Fist
and Luke Cage that now that they've been
canceled as opposed to when they had new
seasons coming out so I think their plan
is to get us all bummed out about the
cancellation then when they announce it
here is for her show we all flip out in
enthusiasm and we all tune in because I
just don't think transferring these
shows to the Disney streaming services
makes any sense it just work Disney
wants to keep their service
family-friendly their Disney and for
fans of these Netflix shows they like
the dark and gritty side of the MCU cuz
yes are you like arguably the ones that
would make the most sense to include
them a little more linked to the
Avengers world
everyone knows the Avengers world
doesn't really acknowledge you know the
Netflix Marvel's a lot of things but in
terms of launching shows on the Disney
streaming services that are more linked
to the MCU films Iron Fist and Luke Cage
if you were to pluck to the defenders
out and they would make the most sense
in terms of like who the defenders could
mesh with the actual Avengers maybe
those guys they have the most heightened
superpowers not saying that they were
trying to like include them in the
Avengers movies just you know I'm
talking about just the umbrella battle
however think about it what were they
what they do exactly well they just do
season 3 on these Disney streaming
services but I mean they would include
season 1 & 2 plus the defenders on the
Disney streaming services those belong
Netflix ok but let's say they go on the
Disney streaming services you got
essentially four or five r-rated seasons
on the disney streaming service or do
audiences have to go to netflix watch
the first few seasons there and then go
all the way to the disney streaming
service where they would then continue
it in this real pg-13 version of it and
which would argue late cause you to lose
fans of the Netflix show it just doesn't
make any sense to me that they would do
that if anything I just truly believe
they're building hype that's just my
personal belief I know there's a lot of
people reporting you know possible
financial reasons of why these shows
were cancelled but for some reason you
call me stupid call me crazy I just
don't buy it I really think this is some
clever marketing to get us hype for a
Heroes for Hire show that will feature
daughters of the Dragon or what would be
cooler is if you get both shows I don't
know what do you guys think do you guys
think I'm right do you guys agree at all
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification melon hey check us out on
the stardust app 30 second reactions
ready to film TV show over trailer it's
downloaded for free it's free to use all
free we all like free things
you